so
i guess it's not like
hey guys please take a seat
[Music]
let us be at peace one another
i'd surprise one another
let us sink in that ocean
and please remember your name
oh it's starting to be crazy here
oh it's starting to begin
the crazy we cooled down the crazy
island
we should do this over and over
and over again
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
thank you for sharing your art your
music your soul so beautifully
thank you
thank you alex thank you guys
victor welcome to the show
thanks for having me on alice
thank you very much very glad to be here
very glad
it's finally
i can see now everything's just
coming to little places here and there
and
it's aligning it's getting more precise
so if i can share with you guys
the spark of the creating
with you i would be a very honored very
honored
likewise
i love that visualization of everything
coming more and more into alignment and
the sparks of the infinite
harmonizing more and more with one
another in this
love light leela
yeah i guess i guess that's the work we
want to do
to each other that's really what we want
to do
that's really what
i'm helping on a more
let's say
[Music]
subtle and precise
and more conscious
also you want to you want to share that
spark
with with with others like really like
consciously focused
precise in their in their calling really
in
what they want to what they want to give
and i'm learning you know i'm learning
with you
i'm learning with with a lot of people
you know it's getting
getting more precise it's getting
exciting really exciting too
i gotta say exciting yes
exciting times really exciting times
really exciting times
i i mean it is you know you gotta look
at the facts and
it's exciting i mean it's a choice okay
okay we can't
we can all agree on that
but you gotta say it's it's exciting
it's exciting [ __ ] times
it's really it's really it's really it
really is
and most exciting for those that are
actually seeing the difference between
the conditioning and the purity
that's most exciting for those that see
the re the shift into permanent
alignment
yeah it's
it's a puzzle it made me looks like
a really tough
puzzle now you say you say puzzle right
yeah
this really tough like puzzle at first
and
and you say like
oh awakening like it's good and now i
can see
and and then no no you don't see you
don't see [ __ ]
the first year you know it's like oh i'm
getting this
this new inside i can i can see it
and six months later one year later
you're like
no no no no no i was blind i was blind
as [ __ ]
uh i thought i was seeing something but
uh
but i was blinding my bow by my own
[ __ ]
and so
yeah and you look yourself at the mirror
like okay i'm full of [ __ ] it's good
it's good it's good it's really good
where am i perpetuating algorithms
that are purely serving my
distortions my lack beliefs
my need to be seen and validated versus
when am i
coming from a sourceful place of truly
serving the creation
yeah you put it very you put very well
put it very well
play very well you don't want to be seen
if that's don't want it you think you
want maybe
a bit of fame of the validation
stuff is pretty it's pretty big in this
society
and this is a big shackle a big shackle
so yeah you you gotta you
you you're brave already
i would say i was ready to say
be brave be brave and the more
braver you get the the more exciting
life will be and the more you won't give
any [ __ ]
any [ __ ] but what other thing
and but it's very prevalent and i
and i really resonated with one of
bentino's
quotes it was like a couple of days ago
like if all this voice keep
echoing on your mind
and i don't remember what what the end
of the sentence say but
but there was a solution at the end
there was something really good i can't
remember
but yeah it's not it's not you but you
gotta extract yourself and
and maybe the echoing because you want
to use those voices to victimize
yourself
you know it's like oh great those voices
again
oh i can i can use them to
not to act or not to not to do or not
not to be what you want to be
it really comes down to this you want to
use that as
a victimization kind of
uh tool
uh you say okay i'm full of [ __ ] i don't
want that
i don't want that and you plunge
guys take the dive
take the [ __ ] dive
thank you
this is most recently become
the fundamental question in the last
month
that has shifted
the view so much
because the level of vigilance now
for every single frame
there was no humility at first it was i
know that i know myself
i accept myself of course what is
what is the concept you mean the nls
family or you mean the the
the awakening type of processes for
both so i'll clarify here
in the know yourself accept yourself
become the creator
that it's very easy to rush and say i've
achieved
step number one and step number two i
know myself
and accept myself completely 100 percent
and so we rarely
check our fraudulence like you were
indicating we rarely check our
[ __ ] and
we in the last month especially for me
there's been a very clear shift
into more hyper
vigilance with devotion to watching each
frame
to become more and more aware of when is
when is atlas purely
aligned with the love light and coming
from source
versus when is there a distortion
algorithm that is trying to come through
and so now there's that distinction it's
so subtle
in every frame to catch that distinction
yeah i love the
you know it's it's it took me some time
to really realize what they were
actually talking about
in this talk where bentino and anurag
talk talk about where exactly you're
coming from
and at first i thought okay i'm coming
from
this past and those experiences and
those stories and and that and this
and
and it really took me some time to no no
no no
it's not about this it's not about the
stories it's not about that
what exactly is your intention what do
you want to give what
can you be clear
on why are you opening your mouth at
this
exact moment
do you know do you know why the [ __ ] are
you even talking
and it was like a major major shift
like a major major [ __ ]
like really beautiful shift and in this
uh in this society like really i saw the
level
of some participants i'm like okay
okay okay i'm like okay i'm a [ __ ]
uh
just well yeah just purify where the
[ __ ] exactly are you coming from
why do you want to talk why what
message do you want to to to release
bring what do you want to give
what do you want to give are you trying
to
get something like
very in a very subtle way
are you exciting are you what are you
what do you want can you
can you check with yourself
that's you know and the more you do that
the more you you'll be amazed
by what words
actually comes out of your mouth after
that
and you don't after like a process
you don't recognize yourself anymore you
don't recognize yourself
you don't want to recognize yourself and
you see no point
you don't see any point again in telling
any stories
i mean it might it might it might be
might be really good sometime
to to tell a story maybe what in what
angle you choose and what message or
sometimes that
but i was amazed by bentino really never
talked about this
no and also his team and
they're really like precise and
and purified in there
in their being doings
but it's very inspiring very inspiring
and it becomes very inspiring for others
and they cannot grab you that's what i
realized like not too long ago
they cannot grasp you anymore and they
feel
people tend to feel kind of lost they
don't know exactly what the [ __ ] you are
anymore like
but where you come from uh i mean
you know you got friends what do you do
what do you it's funny
i love i love to to interact with
this humanity they're there i love it
i have a lot to learn and
but they're fun they're fun
come on man where you from exactly what
have you
done why are you i mean are you high are
you
all the time man
every day it's it's it's really funny
it's really fun
that was such a profound eloquent
way to explain
why are you even talking right now
where is it truly coming from what is
your intention
with speaking are you here trying to
extract something
are you speaking to get validation
are you speaking to fulfill a distortion
of conditioning or
are you silent empty bliss
awaiting the very sourceful
giving
and that distinction is so
profound and you're right that
the need to tell stories
dissolves there's no
need to tell a story to get validated
by somebody else rather the story
acts as a mechanism if it arises
in order to concisely share
a reflection you become more and more
reflecting to
the other self mirror
what is seen as a layer of set
conditioning
and assisting in the process of that
mirror recognizing
that they were coming from conditioning
and that becomes basically the primary
algorithm
is the alchemical
awakening coming from source
for that purpose
yeah you have this way of putting things
like together it's
it's quite fun and i really enjoy that
we enjoy but yeah you're right all right
it's really bad and and and you
you and you won't you want that
you want to be a mirror bentino said
there is a lot of
high demand on mirror consciousness
very high demand i can feel it too
i can see it too very high demand
very high
that's why silence is
when i get back to silence because
victor you cut out you you cut out start
at the very beginning of what you were
saying if you could please
you dropped out of the wi-fi okay
um yeah i was talking about
mirror consciousness
and now there is a very high demand
on neural consciousness and i was
talking about silence
and why sciences is very very very
important right now
and they want to see that sometimes
don't don't don't talk at all
just can you be able to look at
every sisters and brothers out there and
just fall into that you know that's a
good exercise i like to practice a lot
it's
i look i just look at people i um
i place myself in front of them
and i don't say [ __ ] and i just look at
them
and there is all these limiting beliefs
that just pops up
and are you crazy or this is not good
this is not that this is not
socially like right or wrong and this
and you like you feel that your ego is
burning in front of you like no no come
on don't do that don't do it don't do it
like yeah just do it you're gonna see
try to surrender try to not even talk
you don't have to talk not to say
anything
just look at them man see yourself in it
then
and they're gonna see they're gonna
a lot of reflections and a lot of
a lot of beauty beauty in it
a lot of beauty
so do
[Laughter]
[Music]
you it this kind of drill great of
search engine
but yeah it's you really want to do it
like
on uh i think the image is a drill
surgeon
but if you're not devoted you know like
you know all in if you're not
just don't do it you know just
we don't want the the
the half
anyway but you get my point it's either
all in
or you don't go you know so
but it's worth it it's really worth it
it's really [ __ ] worth it guys
it's so worth it you know i was
it was like a couple of days ago i was
like um this ego was i was afraid of
something i didn't want to do and
and i caught myself and i said okay no
more you know
i could see like a pattern and
like something repeating and i just said
okay no more normal
i was really much afraid of at first
and you know each time
each time it works each time it's
amazing you really
purify yourself and you shift you
shift you really shift
really shift
and it's magical yes
it's it's magical it's magical it's
just in one couple of seconds and
bam
you shift
and it's easy you know it's not
it's not like this you think it's tough
it's may sounds tough for you you go at
first but
but the more you do it the more you
you
[Music]
you the easier it gets and you
it becomes like this second nature of
yours
yes and
burning the ego whatever you want to
call it become
it's quite easy and fun it becomes
fun it becomes fun to do it
really fun really funny
it's good you brought up
mirror so
awakening has a lot to do with realizing
that
we are mirrors mirroring
and it has a lot to do with
recognizing when like you're describing
and like we've been talking about when
the mirror
is coming from a place of
purely reflecting the love light
of creation versus when it is
having that dirty spot on it where
it's reflecting a distortion of
conditioning
and so we become more subtly aware when
we
interact with these other selves
that the mirrors sort of have a gradient
from a dirty to a very clean
and in the ultimate analysis
it already is ineffable perfection
and yet simultaneously we recognize
that there are there are
sparks of the infinite expressed in this
creation that have
a higher purity
in their mirroring and that's why like
you indicated they're so highly sought
after
is because they're coming from source
in sharing where
as a reflection the impurity is to the
other self to that other mirror
and so for example for us right now in
this
navy seals of spirituality in the no
limit society
there's a lot of reflecting
that is really insightful
for like victor pointed out
it becomes fun it becomes really
fun to burn the layers of conditioning
and to align oneself with
more pure stewardship
for creation you constantly come
from a place of stewardship
of shepherding yeah
yeah that's it
it becomes an honor
an honor to do that job an
honor like really is
really is and you don't run away from
any responsibilities because you see you
see the beauty in there you see the fun
you see how exciting life can
can become for you can be for you
so you're like [ __ ] you know this ego
conditioning this personality
traits that i was so kind of attached
to you know was like okay this is me
i'm the the fun guy or the weather
wisdom sharing guys or storyteller or
i don't know you know the cool i don't
know i don't know what you want to
identify yourself with
but um but i can see with this
nls family is that even the personality
traits
they're not defining you in any ways
absolutely not
and i actually you want to be
out of any definitions like any
definitions
any definitions you don't you don't need
them
and they're just a way to
to maybe make yourself like make
yourself
safer in some way like okay and that
one this or that
just drop it all drop it off drive it
out
it's not useful it's not useful for you
it's not useful for
for your friends or family
others it's not useful i think it is but
it's really not
and you're very safe you're very safe
you know this
with me
i don't think i can hear you anymore
atlas i don't know muted the mic because
there's a helicopter in la flying over
but it just went past
okay i get it
yeah guys so just drop the definitions
and
you know have fun
right it's really
just let it go
[Laughter]
no i've
victor why is your calling
around people experiencing the craziness
of
creation
why
and what does it mean to you
why i i don't know
exactly the why
um
i found i found it like very
healing and
and i guess i just also love
like popping
all those bubbles you know
you go outside and you see all those
people and
and there's this big bubble around the
head
it's true continue pointing out but it's
it's very true that's also what i feel
i love to pop that bubble
you see
oh what the [ __ ] is going on well
exactly
you see people like very robotic acting
like yeah very much
very [ __ ] much i'm like just
like what what the [ __ ] is going on i
want them to
too
i guess it also has to do with uh
where i come from as an individual and
my experiences is and
this
like because i i thought at some point
being being seen as
crazy was really unsafe
for me
and there has been this
healing process around that
really healing process around that
so i get to accept that
and to see as to see it as really like a
perfection
and as you know
this this creates or wanting to
experience itself
that way you know that way that way you
want to drive them
nuts you want to drive them nuts and
that's what that's what i learned
that's what really excites me to drive
them
nuts to drive those people around nuts
it's it's it's really fun
it's very little it's very subtle or
sometimes it's gross
but it's like what the [ __ ] is going on
why are you even saying this
it doesn't make any sense it
can be all you this we're talking like
about stories and
you know this need of the humanity to
justify itself you know permanently
about
where you come from what you've done why
you realize so on so on so on
so it just like became it
naturally for me as i was into my
purif purifying processes
to just like starting just starting to
tell
like [ __ ] like it's just like very
crazy crazy stories
crazy unbelievable stories
unbelievable the guys to say what what
is it
what exactly is this
[Laughter]
it's really you know it's just like it
became just
like second nature yeah i like very
i wasn't controlling anything i wasn't
trying to manipulate my way out of here
out of there
it's just big became like really
natural really me
really yeah really
i don't know what is like purified
purified so why do i want to do that i
guess it has to do with the
shattering shattering exploding just
those bubbles or
trying to
[Music]
they have to do something you know at
the end
and i also want them to exercise
their free will i see i see very weak
free will around me very well weak
focused oriented being so i want them to
recalibrate give them this opportunity
to like affirm themselves like no no i
don't want that
so get the [ __ ] out and um i'm going to
push them push push push until
you know that all the layers of
conditioning of
what should be done what shouldn't be
done
just like dropped melt
and they have no choice to act
intuitively
i come from this source kind of
like location
even if there's no location but you get
my point
so i want them to drop it all
and you know go
seek what really it is you want to do
what really it is you want to
please do it you know act do something
that's that's one way to put my calling
is you're like pranking them
a prankster
yeah yeah yeah
um i see so
there's the experience for you
of being a unique spark of the infinite
that is excited
about a highest
calling around
the unlocking of the
frozen will of those
that are following the scripted robotic
algorithms that we
liberated ourselves from
we liberated ourselves from that because
we were
pursuing as we unlocked more of our
frozen
will it enabled us to pursue more
metaphysical truth in this north star
position
relentlessly and in the process gain
more of that spiritual mass
and then turn and serve
the creation unlocking more of their
frozen
will and in a sense it can look like
moving ice which is like these egoic
layers of conditioning that we've been
talking about
and this very robotic automata style
behavior
to vapor which is more of the sovereign
will
choice highest excitement north stars
igniting the planetary awakening being a
pure
shepherd a pure steward
and i love that spark of the infinite
it's a really important spark of the
infinite
and we
typically don't
see that as important
in the unlocking of
the frozen will because sometimes
in the higher navy seals of spirituality
and i've noticed this with
the way people have reflected to you
before it's
can be reflected as well
why do you desire
where are you coming from that you
desire to playfully melt
the cages as jordan bates says one of
our friends that why do you desire to
playfully melt the cages of those in the
matrix
and unlock their will why do you have
the
the lack belief or what are you trying
to achieve and
i i don't see it that way i see that
angle
to it because it's an important angle
for those that are coming not
from source and doing that but i really
feel a lot of purity
when it comes from you i feel you're
very
silent you're very still and you're
coming from
a place of truth of wanting to
be a shepherd for unlocking
the frozen will and so because you come
from there and you're refining your
ability to come from there
i trust where you're coming from
well thank you thank you very much and i
gotta say
people as us to understand that it's not
it's not very comfortable due to
[Music]
uh and also where i was coming from i
was
i i wasn't that guy i wasn't my guys
cool i wasn't the head
yeah people can see that tenancy wanting
to
to mess with people trying to shatter
those bubbles
trying to to be a dick and be really
provoking
and provoking statement
and just like acting and
playing and just like mess
you're messing around you're amazing
really and you become this
pain in the ass and people are asked to
[ __ ] what is going on i gotta
gotta do something and sometimes
people was to understand that it's not
it's not always comfortable like people
like they don't like you at all
and you you become this pain yes this
dick and just it's not
i was ready i was ready to and i'm
really ready for more
but it's sometimes yeah sometimes it can
be seen as pretty tough like
people projecting all this [ __ ] and
and and
but it's it's good it's really good
but yeah man i see someone fishing like
way too close to the sea
i want to push that dude i want to push
it
oh man
and it took me a long time to
to see that as a spark you know the
the creator like really it took me
why you know why why why why
because there's this you know
compassionate
nice kind of conditioning
you know of what spirituality is about
and
what unity is about and so on and so on
and so on
and sometimes like okay and they're all
projecting this and
okay i'm confused because i really want
to
i really want to mess with them
and
and i love it you know i love it
drive them nuts
uh yeah man you got
sometimes you you get killed you get you
get your ass kicked and you
get punched and
but it's fun it's really fun and i i
really see it as a
i i think the native uh the cold they
call that particular spark
um ayoka the the
the aoka the i think it's there i don't
know i haven't
searched a lot but i i think there is a
term for
for that particular spark so i was kind
of amazed once
uh a guy just uh i've met
like told me yeah yeah the natives
there's the spark i'm very much
respected and
i was like oh wow [ __ ] uh okay
okay good okay
man because to be clear at some point i
thought i was
i was being worthy of deserving like to
be locked up
because i was i was looking at this park
and what what what it could become
and i was like oh wow this this is gonna
get like
really messy for a lot of people a lot
of people
and i was like
why what do i deserve
being worthy of being locked up
and locked in and because
this is gonna make a lot of noise
and
[Laughter]
but no no you you
and thank you because you really put it
like very
[Music]
very beautifully
like there is a place for for that kind
of spark
and if anybody is watching
and if you can relate that you want to
mess around and be
provoking and just have fun with them
and
fun with people and pushing them
yeah it's it's really beautiful
it is it is guys
it's
[Music]
you know there's no
there's so many ways to to to be
spiritual whatever the [ __ ] you want to
call it
there's no there's no one path
two path three path there's
what you choose and what your heart you
know is calling you to do
and to be and yeah it might
you must really piss off like a lot of
people
a lot of people a lot of people
but
[Music]
why the [ __ ] would you care what the
[ __ ] would you care
you're going to attract beautiful people
that are going to accept you for you are
going to attract an amazing amazing life
amazing life you know
at that moment when you become like
really authentic and true to yourself
and you're like okay i'm that i want to
express
that part of the creator i want to
express
that
well it's
it's beautiful it's beautiful
beautiful absolutely beautiful
thank you thank you very much atlas for
accepting in a way myself it's been kind
of a long road for me
and um
you know yeah i've had this tendency to
to
yeah thinking that i was i was too much
for this world that was too much too
much
too much because it's it's every day
every day i'm i'm i'm having
to confront like doing like a mess or
it's
it's
almost on a day-to-day basis
sometimes it can be draining it's like
but it's it's very much necessary
very much necessary oh yeah man
the the but it's i've had this day three
happened and uh
and it's he's been such
there's been this amazing moment where i
realized okay i
got they tried to lock they tried to
lock me up you know i've been
they they sent me to the psych ward they
tried to put me in jail
uh
i've been like
i got my ass kicked like pretty bad like
really bad
i've had like oh a lot of stuff a lot of
stories and
but i persist i i really persisted
and now the cops in my in my in my city
they leave me the [ __ ] alone they leave
me to [ __ ] alone
because they know they cannot do
anything that will change me
and what i want to become
and so i encourage encourage
everybody to persist and
to trust themselves trust themselves
and trust their spark
trust your spark
trust your [ __ ] spark yeah that's
yeah trust your spark
trusty yeah
i love you
great
[Laughter]
the recognition that you created
the forces that
try to stop your spark in order to test
your earnestness to it
yeah i
i just couldn't give up man i
i couldn't
i couldn't
are you it's like your soul
somehow at stake you know you know those
moments
those moments where
you say okay okay okay okay
i can lose a bit of my soul here i mean
you never lose truly anything but you
you get my porn
well i can't regain some of it like okay
i don't know [ __ ] that
i'm gonna take control there
out of the space of infinite possibility
that the
critical pivotal splitting
moments as you
share in this trajectory space
it could be so easy to
fall into one of these lower
trajectories
that are not in your highest excitement
towards that north star towards that
calling
and and to be hyper vigilant
with every beautiful frame
and to fully unleash
the will the choice the self-awareness
the sovereignty
as the creator
in divine transcendent
noble pursuit of that highest calling
repeatedly checking
as we mentioned earlier too
are we behaving for the ego conditioning
or are we coming from source in pure
service
to creation and so
in a sense we have two
pivotal checks with our hyper vigilance
one of them is is this the calling the
north star the highest excitement
the thumb on the trajectory space and
the other is
am i truly purely coming
from source
and over to over time we trust ourselves
more and more and we
monitor ourselves less and less
yeah because we know what we're we're
doing there
we're doing the work
and you put the intention and you know
you know you're doing it
you you you really much know
and doubts will
just leave you know by themselves they
will
leave really easily
no more because you know you know you're
doing the work you know you're doing it
so just don't stop don't
it's really worth it
it's really worth it
it really is and
anybody tell you the opposite you know
truly about you know affirming yourself
okay okay i'm doing the work i'm it's
it's a courageous work you're doing
really
courageous work you're doing
really courageous one
so you don't let don't let anybody
any other thoughts make you believe that
it is not true
never you know never
never
now you see it's going to get like
funnier and funnier and
exciting and you're going to gain on the
self confidence and you're gonna see
it like as really humility humility is
self-confidence that's why i always
was attracted to this pentino guy
because
self-confidence is humility you're gonna
see that as
true and you're gonna gain it
more and more and more and more you're
gonna
trust yourself
and even in spiritual communities even
even
in every communities okay
you're gonna stop positioning yourself
in
victimized position and
you're gonna stop positioning yourself
and just
be it you're gonna you're gonna be it
you're really gonna be
it okay there's gonna be no more
just gonna be it
stop positioning yourself stop
stop it all stop it all see what
like say what you have to say say what
it's
in your heart really
what is it in your heart really
really really and free yourself
from any any
any type of shackles and
you know it took me some time to see
humanity as very stupid for me i was you
know i was projecting
i was always like maybe you know they
have to teach me something and to
i was positioning myself in this human
team
very not reclused
but in um
i cannot say that but i thought we
i thought you know like compassion and
humility was to see them
no i was trying to they're here and
you're here you're trying to help them
and
you know like
you know this mask thing i have to say i
have to say
you know this is wow this is
oh [ __ ] man
in the car that's that that's the most
you know how could you no
want i can could you not want to
experience and to
make peop people experiencing like the
stupidity of craziness
when they're at that level of
consciousness to
to wear a [ __ ] mask in the car
be afraid of the wheel
i don't know you know i don't know what
they're afraid of in the car
they're alone what it is what is it i
don't
i don't get it what is it
oh my god
oh
so fearful must avoid the
virus even by myself in the car while
driving must wear masks
fear fear fear programming programming
programming fear
fear fear fear fear fear fear fear fear
fear i'm amazed i'm amazed i'm amazed
so pop gently
playfully wisely
those bubbles
melt the cages
the very chainless chains
the very matrix-less matrix
we created ourselves the very
catalysts that are these onion layers of
conditioning
that we wake up to that then
serve the ignition of our own awakening
and so what it sounds like your
beautiful
calling
and experience now and
moving forward is is the process of
how to be
maximal optimal precision
jedi in the process
of popping bubbles
wisely gracefully
with love compassion
and respecting the art of free will
and choice in the process
yeah those that was a big one for me at
some point like oh
i'm trying to mess with that i'm not
trying to to take away the free will and
so on so
on i'm bad i'm
messing with my people
uh no no i'm inviting them
i'm inviting my my sisters and brothers
to to exercise their [ __ ] free will
to exercising you know
please at some point like please do
something you know
what what is that i'm like i'm gonna
have to to spit on your face and to to
you know take your pee like in front of
your kid
what the [ __ ] is this i'm uh
uh what the [ __ ] is this
what the [ __ ] is this
i'm throwing i
see them like driving with the mask and
i i have eggs i i wanna i wanna throw
like a like a bunch of eggs at the cars
and say hello
well it's it's like you know you're
scared like okay
let's just you know let's
let's do it let's try to pop your bubble
because you you really are a joke
you're you really are a [ __ ] joke and
i'm
i can't take it you know at some point
i'm not
i can't i can't take it i just couldn't
take it anymore
i couldn't take it and right now i'm um
i'm again at this point where
i i can't take it i just
all this kobe thing okay
i think it's time to embody
into and and to
mess with those guys because
they're really closed off and really
[ __ ] stupid
really [ __ ] arrogant
they they think they wanna you know it's
like yeah
i'm helping others i'm like come
on man come on man
come on you [ __ ] hypocrite you never
helped
anybody except yourself and now you want
to help
everybody by wearing [ __ ] masks
come on not with me
not with me i do not believe you for
any any any any any any second
i don't i don't believe you i don't
believe you and i'm gonna mess with you
i'm gonna mess with you
i'm gonna prank you and i'm gonna make
you see
you know make you see that you're full
of [ __ ]
i'm very much arrogant very much
and i very much like to mess to mess
with those like
the most arrogant ones you know i can i
can see i can
i'm scanning i see a dick i see a very
big like a
very big dick like very like this
this dude this guy like very
trying to to impose like his his view on
the world
like the the with the covet it's been
like really amazing like oh
maybe you know wearing the mask but you
shoot with the mess like
every but like a lot of people like turn
cops
like like in you know one day two days
they were ready for me like to be the
the cops in town
oh you're not wearing the mask you're
not respecting the the thing not
respecting that you're not respecting
this
um okay okay i felt victor
the request is coming through right now
to
encourage or suggest
as much as you see
that the
matrix narratives are ones that you
created and are also the ones that you
are
playfully melting popping
as much as you see that to also see them
as stories as well
and to notice that the only true
work is the work that we've been talking
about throughout the show which is this
inward work
of both aligning with the highest
calling
and then the relentless
self-purification
engine of perpetually checking
where you're coming from in the process
and becoming
more and more wise and precise
and loving and compassionate and coming
from source
in every single one of your bubble
realities
clicking for an interaction
[Music]
i love you so much
[Laughter]
yeah i was trying maybe to give some
some context about
why i felt the urge
to you know this inside
urge to pop bubbles and
[Music]
shattered some way
yeah yeah the more that you
refine where you're coming from
with your calling
and with the urge of melting
the cages playfully of liberating
people's will from the frozen to the
vapor
liberating their sovereignty
enabling and unlocking their highest
callings
the more that you refine yourself in
that process
the more you'll frictionlessly and
harmonically
navigate like a jedi
every single one of these bubble
realities that
clicks and so that's
what is coming through right now is
telling the atlas
soul that
the victor soul is on trajectory
for that capacity
that ability that level of
magic and wizardry
as long as victor focuses on that inward
purification repeatedly
yeah yeah
yeah yeah
do
go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
well well that's true it's right
i just felt it you know at some point it
was
i mean you know the story started again
i gotta say it's it's very it's very
easy
i found out i i found out what really it
is about but
i until then i just you know i just stay
there and
and they're nothing you know like i wait
you know
i'm getting old
victor i would like to make the request
of the victor soul to
wrap us up with a
another musical artistic
performance oh you're asking that dude
again to come back
who has given
[Music]
oh
you can't find yourself in there
i'm invited
don't try to be somebody else
oh my friends
i'm inviting you
to be what you
meant to be
in the first place
forget where you know
forget everything
[Music]
some kind of fake safety
they might still want to carry
please my lords please give
me substance in the substance as
well give me what i want to
accomplish what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah hey
[Music]
sir
thank you
thank you very much